SPEAKER 1: What
Joseph will eventually
come to be known for isn't a
dreamer but a reader of dreams.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
"And Jacob dwelled in the land
of his father's sojournings,
in the land of Canaan.
This is the lineage of Jacob.
Joseph, 17 years old,
was tending the flock
with his brothers,
assisting the son of Bilhah
and the sons of Zilpah,
the wives of his father.
And Joseph brought ill report
of them to their father.
And Israel loved Joseph
more than all his sons
for he was a child
of his old age,
and he made him an
ornamented tunic.
And his brother saw it was their
father who loved Joseph more
than all his brothers and
they hated him and could not
speak a kind word to him."
My students are
often taken aback
because Joseph brought ill
report of them to their father.
Students often wonder, is
this just the youngest brother
being a snitch?
Hold on to that because I
think the text later will
start to answer our question.
Oftentimes, we think
that the brothers simply
despise Joseph because
of his ornamented tunic.
But the text sets it up that
the ornamented tunic is actually
a representation of
his favorite status.
"And Joseph dreamed a dream
and told it to his brothers
and they hated him all the more.
And he said to them,
'Listen, pray to this dream
that I dreamed.
And look, we were binding
sheaves in the field, and look,
my sheaf arose and actually
stood up, and look,
your sheaves drew round
and bowed to my sheaf.'
And his brother said to him,
'Do you mean to reign over us?
Do you mean to rule us?'
And they hated him all
the more for his dreams
and for his words."
There are a few interesting
things going on here.
What Joseph will eventually
come to be known for
isn't a dreamer but
a reader of dreams.
Here, we begin in
the narrative, we
see Joseph himself
is the dreamer.
"And he dreamed
yet another dream
and recounted it
to his brothers.
And said, 'Look, I dreamed
a dream again, and look,
the sun and the moon and the 11
stars were bowing down to me.'
And he recounted it to his
father and to his brothers.
And his father
rebuked him and said,
'What is this dream
that you have dreamed?
Shall we really come, I and
your mother and your brothers,
to bow down before
you to the ground?'
And his brothers
were jealous of him,
while his father kept
the thing in mind."
And again, we do not get his
understanding of this dream.
It's just these enigmatic
dreams at this point.
"And his brothers went to
graze their father's flock
at Shechem.
And Israel said to
Joseph, 'You know,
your brothers are
pastoring at Shechem.
Come let me send you to them.'
And he said to him, 'Here I am.'
And he said, 'Go pray to see
how your brothers fare and how
the flocks fare and
bring me back word.'"
Ah, now we get to
see perhaps that
which preceded
there in Chapter 37
that Joseph isn't bringing ill
report just in and of himself.
It's his father who's
asking him to go and look
after his brothers to see
how the flock is faring.
And, of course, he goes and
he looks for his brothers.
"And they saw him from
afar before he drew near,
and they plotted against
him to put him to death.
And they said to each other,
'Here comes that dream master.
And so now, let us kill him and
fling him into one of the pits.
And we can say a vicious
beast has devoured him,
and we shall see what
comes of his dreams.'"
I find this moment fascinating.
One, notice, they're
all speaking together.
Each said to each other.
It's as if they're speaking
in a unified manner.
And I find this
fascinating because what
you saw in the dream were
all of the sheaves on one
side and Joseph there
against all the others.
And this is going to play
out in the narrative for us.
All the brothers united
against one brother
who is, in fact, the
beloved of his father.
"And Reuben heard and came
to his rescue and said,
'We must not take his life.'
And Reuben said to
them, 'Shed no blood.
Fling him into this pit in the
wilderness and do not raise
a hand against him,' so that
Reuben might rescue him from
their hands to bring
him back to his father."
We have to stop here.
I think this is a
really important detail
in the narrative.
First off, you have to realize
Reuben is the eldest son.
Whatever favoritism is
being heaped upon Joseph,
this really is something
that ought to be
going to Reuben as first born.
And so now, think about what
happens if Reuben's plan comes
to fruition.
What happens?
Just think about it.
All the brothers over
here versus Joseph
the one over here.
And then they fling
him into the pit,
and then Reuben rescues him and
brings him back to his father
so that Reuben can stand there
in solidarity with Joseph,
his father's beloved
son, and perhaps
get some of Joseph's favoritism,
some of the light that shines
on Joseph to shine a little bit
on Reuben who, of course, has
fallen out of his
father's good graces.
"And it happened when
Joseph came to his brothers
that they stripped him of his
tunic, the ornamented tunic
that he had on him.
And they took him and
flung him into the pit,
and the pit was empty.
There was no water in it.
And they sat down to eat bread,
and they raised their eyes
and saw and, look, a
caravan of Ishmaelites
was coming bearing gum and
balm and ladanum on their way
down to Egypt.
And Judah said to
his brothers, 'What
gain is there if we kill our
brother and cover up his blood?
Come, let us sell him to the
Ishmaelites and our hand will
not be against him for he is
our brother, our own flesh.'"
And it's important
to take note here
that it is, in fact,
Judah is the one who
wants to find some
sort of material gain
in selling Joseph into slavery.
Just take note of
that because this
is going to become important
at the end of the story.
"And his brothers agreed, and
they sold Joseph into Egypt.
And then Reuben came
back to the pit and look,
Joseph was not in the pit,
and he rent his garments,
and he came back to his
brothers, and he said,
'The boy is gone, and
I, where can I turn?'
And they took Joseph's
tunic and slaughtered a kid
and dipped the tunic
in blood, and they
sent the ornamented tunic and
had brought it to their father,
saying, 'This is a
beautiful moment.
Recognize, pray, is it
your son's tunic or not?'
And he recognized it, and he
said, 'It is my son's tunic.'"
Just think about
this for a moment.
They're showing this
kind of condensed symbol
of their father's favoritism.
And he can see it
standing of Joseph
who's gone but also
that condensed symbol
of their brother's hatred for
him of his favored status.
"And Jacob rent his clothes
and put on sackcloth
round his waist and mourn
for his son many days.
And all his sons and all his
daughters rose to console him,
and he refused to be
consoled and said,
'Rather, I will go down to my
son in Sheol mourning,' and he
keened for him."
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlight Series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.